so check what's been bugging you later
Dorian Murray or your ex-girlfriend no
[Music]
hurricane I get it I got a form is you
happy for you okay okay yeah I don't
know if people know that well each of
these low pressure systems that build up
in the in the in the South Atlantic they
each get named alphabetically
alternating boy named girl name so
that's how you know how deep into the
hurricane season you are right the storm
season but how far down the alphabet
you've gone Wow
and so I do you think people know how
they're formed okay I can no good I need
to earth good yeah you the only Derrick
oh wow look at that
any planet you want is there any of the
eight planets get over it okay so we all
know Earth rotates right
and on the equator they actually rotate
faster than anybody else there's speed
through space this faster makes them
because they make a day's trip like
everybody else does but they ain't going
25,000 miles okay and anyone else has
gone left less all right
that's fact number one fact number two
let's throw a low-pressure system in the
Atlantic mm-hmm and you're a puffy cloud
which way you're gonna go you're gonna
push me Lord North yeah so all the
system will push you north towards that
low-pressure system right and I'm and
another puffy cloud north of the good
low pressure system which way are you
gonna go I'm gonna go I'm gonna go south
through the low-pressure system attracts
all clouds right oh wow
calling all clouds so there they go now
that if that kept up they would just
sort of meet in the middle right but
that could that's not what happened
that's not what happens because
everybody has sideways motion and I'm a
cloud south of that low-pressure system
and I go towards it but wait a minute I
have speed that will overtake it rise
I'm going sideways faster than it is
okay it'll overtake it to the right
right now you're above and you're headed
towards it you're gonna fall behind it
to the right and that creates a circular
a general circulation of all weather
around a low-pressure system and that's
what we call a storm and so Chuck it
probably makes sense that if you repeat
this in the
southern hemisphere everything is going
to move in the opposite direction so
storms in the southern hemisphere
actually rotate clockwise and that would
mean a storm on the equator wouldn't
know which way to rotate the kind of
storm free zones a storm free zone nice
there you go so Chuck the fact that
things circulate in this way with clouds
from below overtaking and from above
falling behind that was studied by a guy
named Coriolis and it's called the
Coriolis force there's not really a
force but it looks like there's a force
pushing things and that's what happens
when you're on rotating surfaces and not
only that how do you get a cloud in the
first place you need moist air that's
unstable which means it'll rise right so
if you have moist rising air it's colder
up there than down here right you know
that you have been an airplane and look
at the temperature outside the plane not
very pleasant now it's like 40 below
zero right because all the sunlight
passes through our transparent
atmosphere hits the ground in the ground
heats the air right the Sun doesn't heat
the atmosphere except in some very
special layers I think the Sun heats the
ground
the granite eats the air so the
radiation of heat back yeah where the
Energy's coming correct that's what we
feel because that becomes that back in
infrared that's how that works
comes in as visible light gets we
radiate it as infrared okay yeah so what
happens so the ground absorbs it and it
RiRi dates it later in the day so the
hottest time of day is not at peak
heating no it's a little later when the
ground to do in fact two or three
o'clock in the afternoon okay the
hottest month of the year is not June
which has the first day of summer the
longest stay there that has the most
ground heat no like because there's a
delay the oceans pick up this energy
right okay there's heat there's thermal
energy and it gives it off later later
so when is hurricane season it's August
September right okay because earth is
beginning to cool down but you have this
heat source that's still that still and
it's a moisture source right and it's
unstable Wow so the air rises makes
clouds low-pressure system gathers you
have a circulating system thus is born
or hurricane Oh
boom boom look at that now hurricanes
they'll lower the low pressure system is
alright the more clouds it attracted the
more devastating the hurricane is the
faster it'll turn everything look at
that yeah so that's that's that now as
it sort of they can sometimes to make a
left turn into the Caribbean right as it
so devastatingly does for the island
countries there or can go up the coast
right all right now if it goes over land
doesn't have the heat from the ocean and
so generally they lose their punch let's
see if there's some moisture exactly
there generally lose their punch but if
it stays along the coast it can stay
potent and it'll move very fast I mean a
longer surface 10 miles 20 miles an hour
tops right okay that means if you do if
you run do the math for how long it
would take you to go up the coast you
can take weeks guaranteeing that
someplace along this coast it's gonna
land fall during high tide somebody's
gonna get a high tide our Akane right
and that's bad because high tide can be
bad enough but a high tide that would be
during full moon or during new moon
that's what I mean by high tide every
day has a high tide talk about big high
tide right full moon new moon the
hurricane hits you during one of those
you get extra title you get storm surge
as well as the tide surge well and so
that can particularly in the era of
global warming where where oh she levels
are slowly creeping up you can end up
going over gates and in jetties and
levees or whatever is holding back the
water you can bleach that just takes an
inch to breach it and that's not that's
it out of the city flood the city as
long as the hurricane is there you flood
the city get your buckets out and that's
what happened in hurricane sandy here
and I lost our electricity downtown yeah
because they went over the sidewalks all
it was yeah yeah and the storm surge was
not even a foot it just has to be
whatever is whatever was above above as
all you need it above the limit yeah you
got it
whole underground parking locks cars
were bobbing out of the parking lot
so so here we are in hurricane season
that's what's going on
there you go everything you wanted to
know about hurricanes and more right
there hmm
so if you did Coriolis or hurricanes or
just start talking make sure that you
subscribe and hit the bell
so you don't miss an episode and if
you're so inclined make sure that you
support us on patreon and as over
[Applause]
you
[Music]